donc
[Rires]
chez lui
quand même ça passe bien
chez lui il entend du bruit comme des
gens qui roulent sur la moquette dans
son salon et tout descend tu peux
inquiet et là il voit son chien et sa
chienne qui manifestement viennent de
s'accoupler puisqu'ils sont ce qui
arrive souvent chez les chiens ils sont
collés comme on dit c'est-à-dire en fait
pour parler après 20h il a mis sa mite
dans le feu et ça s'apprible
la femelle a la serrer les cales pieds
le sang il reste bon c'est bon et il
peut plus ressortir donc il est un peu
emmerdé regarde sa montre il est minuit
minuit il appelle le véto dit tant pis
bon c'est un mec sympa je l'appelle je
l'appelle le véto et il lui explique le
truc et ouais le mec il lui dit très
très posément il lui dit bon alors ce
que ce qu'on va faire
vous allez je vais raccrocher moi
j'allais poser votre téléphone au pied
du mal
faites bien attention que il soit pas
sur silence je veux qu'il soit sur
sonnerie au plus fort il vous le posez
et moi je vais rappeler et le mec il a
un peu inquiet il dit vous croyez que ça
va le faire débander il dit j'en sais
rien mais avec moi ça a bien marché il y
a cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]